I wanted to briefly mention this I
haven't haven't got a lot of attention
uh post millennial says NFL legend Rob
gronowski recently spoke out against the
idea of men playing in women's sports
telling Fox News that there's really no
argument one could otherwise make
there's been a push over the last
several years by trans activists to
force women to accept men who identifies
transgender into sporting competitions
obviously we know that um gronowski said
in a recent interview on the subject
there's really no thoughts to really
share it's obvious there are men sports
for men there's women sports for women
it should just stay like that it's just
as simple as that man there's really no
argument there should really be no
conversation about it how it's been is
how it should be men play men's sports
women play women's sports it's as simple
as that it's really unfair if a man went
into a woman's Sport and played it it
just doesn't uh make much sense to
me and obviously he's right about that
it's good that he's saying
it but I just think that this you we
talked in the in the opening about uh
Christian uh the the failure of
Christian leaders across the country to
speak up against the gender ideology
Madness um or or you know and many of
them waiting until it's safest until
other people have done the work so that
they can swoop in and say oh this is
good I'm happy about this um and even
Pat themselves on the back for it and I
think we see a similar thing happening
in athletics with uh some of these you
know a few professional athletes or
former professional athletes now coming
out and saying yeah this shouldn't be
happening when when it's when it's
completely when it's much safer it's
much safer now well number one because
you're not in the league anymore and
number two because um there were many
there were actually a small number of
people who are willing to make this
point back when it was
unpopular uh and now we finally have
some people jumping on the bandwagon for
most homeowners window replacement isn't
something they've done before and for
many it isn't something they really want
to do but rather something they have to
do well if you've put off replacing the
windows in your home because it's too
expensive I have great news for you you
can now get a free inhome window
consultation and a free price quote from
Renewal by Anderson Renewal by Anderson
signature service is committed to giving
you the best customer experience
possible through the perfect combination
of the best people in the industry a
superior process and an exclusive
product right now Renewal by Anderson is
offering a free inhome or virtual
consultation on durable quality
affordable Windows patio doors uh all
for Z down zero payments and zero
interest for a year text Walsh to 200
300 for your free consultation to save
300 $5 off every window and $750 off
every door those savings won't last long
so be sure to check it out by texting
Walsh to 2300 that's Walsh to 200 300
texting privacy policy in terms of
conditions posted at text plan. us
texting enrolls for recurring automated
text marketing messages message data
rates may apply reply stop topped out go
to windowappointment now.com for full
offer
details but just imagine you know even
taking the men and women sports issue on
its own
imagine
if I don't
know five years
ago um a large percentage of
professional athletes men and women had
simply come out and said this is wrong
we can't do this this is crazy of course
we can't do
this imagine if that had happened I mean
this issue would have been would have
been would have been solved pretty
quickly but they were terrified to say
anything and now we're hearing from them
okay if you'd like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there Godspeed